welcome back to dc thursdays it's
another thursday and
we have another awesome guest on the
show which i'll introduce
in just a minute uh i'm pete soterling
i'm the founder of data council and data
community fund as many of you know
and i'm here to guide you through the
wild west
of the data ecosystem we've been
fortunate to have on lots of awesome
founders
of lots of awesome open source project
leaders and authors
today we have someone who's actually
floating across both categories
which will be uh turned into a great
conversation so
before we get started and introduce our
guest i wanted to thank our sponsor
ibm who's been supporting
data council and the dc thursday show
we're super excited and very grateful
for them and their support
they have an online community for data
scientists that you should check out
we'll put the link
in the chat to the right of the video um
so make sure you you check out what ibm
is doing for the community they're
believers in open source
um they have nlp projects they have
ethical ai projects
they contribute to the python community
and so we hope that you'll check them
out and
tell them tell them that you are
grateful for their support as well
as we do every week we are going to open
the
the chat to questions so feel free to
jump in at any time if you have
questions for our guest
we want to make this sort of a cross
between a podcast and a
call-in radio show so the best of all
generations
are right here at your fingertips so
feel free to sound off in the chat and
we'll do our best to get to your
questions so um without further ado
i want to introduce matt rocklin who's
here
matt is the co-founder and ceo
of coiled computing which is the company
behind desk
and prior to that uh matt worked at
nvidia
he worked at continuum analytics he's
obviously the author of dasc which we'll
get into which is fascinating story
um
there's lots of tasks there's a large
community if i don't say that everyone
else will jump on me
sharing the credit from the start which
is which is great so thanks for
for jumping in that's well said um and
uh
before kicking off or or having
something to do with kicking off the
desk movement
matt was a researcher at sandia national
laboratories he has a phd
in computer science from the university
of chicago and he also has a degree from
uc berkeley so matt those are
quite the credentials um thanks for
making time to chat with us
oh that's great i love i love doing
these things it's a fun
the whole like my story is like a small
version of what generally speaking
python has been through
over the last couple of decades and it's
a it's a wild and unexpected run
personally and from the community
perspective and we were chatting about
that a little bit um before we came
online um but we'll we'll get into some
ecosystem discussions about how python
has tracked over time
before we do that i just want to sort of
understand
um the earliest days of your career sort
of leading up to
your work on desk what what were those
days like
you know you studied math um you have a
cs degree
um like how did you sort of merge those
things into this
this interest in data like when when did
data start to become
a thing for you did it become a thing
for you or are you just a distributed
systems guy who happens to be sort of
playing in the python world yeah and
actually quite the opposite so i
actually started
in undergrad doing you know physics and
math and astronomy
so very much came from more of a
scientific practitioner's background
but i think as a kid i had a little ti
calculator that i would play with a lot
and probably
and so i knew how to program and that it
was odd how much of an advantage that
gave me
back in you know 2000 when working on on
technology problems or working on
science problems and so i was never a
very good scientist or very good
researcher
but i was i was in i was an order of
magnitude more effective
at enabling my peers to do their
research by
helping them work through computational
problems and so that very quickly became
a strong
inducement to actually not do that
science stuff but kind of support
scientists
with computation um
i ended up sort of falling into sort of
the the u.s
department of energy national labs the
career because that's maybe like a
good mix of sort of practical problems
and technical problems
um but in doing so i was also working on
the side in open source
uh and in python and that just had like
an order of magnitude
more feedback and if i was having a lot
of bigger impact
and so pretty quickly after being at
sandia i decided to jump ship
and i joined a continuum at the time
which then became anaconda
it's where pretty much all of the sort
of open source for-profit people went
at that time and it was a really
exciting time for
anybody who wanted to have a big impact
in open source python and doing science
and data science that was where you went
so that was maybe my my transformation
first
science to computing and then from maybe
like
academic ish to open source commercial
open source companies which were very
new at the time it was still quite uh
quite strange
great and so it was around 2 2015 that
you dropped the
the paper on desk if i'm not mistaken is
that right
yeah a lot of things happened around
that year yeah so i was brought in
at anaconda to think about making python
faster
i had done a lot of open source work and
they wanted to attract people who could
make
python more attractive generally maybe
being a so goes pythons or
as python goes so goes anaconda
and anaconda was concerned at the time
about spark which was gaining a lot of
traction at the time
arc was this kind of like other data
process ecosystem
apart from python and there was some
existential concern
and so i was thinking a lot about how to
take the existing
python ecosystem and paralyze it how do
we take you know numpy and pandas and
psychic learn and what eventually became
pi torch and other tools
how do we scale those out to many
machines that became
lots of projects at first but eventually
desk
and so there's this notion of blocked
algorithms
i don't want to get too too much into
the the implementation details but
um are blocked algorithms used both in
desk and in spark is this the general
category of
processing that we're that we're
considering um
yeah let me think about that for a
second uh so das does many things and so
people sometimes ask like what does that
do and it does
lots of stuff so i like i want to avoid
putting it into a box
but let me maybe uh answer a slightly
different question
which is that so with with task like we
didn't want to do what spark did spark
recreated an entirely new
data framework to solve data processing
problems
with das we had the python frameworks
already around we had numpy we had
pandas
and so the goal was well you know if i
have if i have a really big data set can
i just have
you know 50 machines each of which are
using just pandas
and reuse a lot of that same code and so
a lot of das algorithms early on were
around
uh pretending you had one big pandas
data frame
when you actually have 50 pandas data
frames and then you're building
parallel algorithms around them that
reuse the existing
uh ecosystem the existing code we
already had from you know decades of
development
so that's maybe a case where das and
spark differ a bit and that brings up
this idea of blocked
how do we reuse what we have to gain
something new to up level
our existing workflows i love the
framing of how you
walk through that in the uh intro to the
paper because
um you explicitly define that
um why would we throw away all this work
and all these
thousands of man hours of engineering
time and research
in the python ecosystem that have been
battle tested and tried and true
just because we can't run these things
on multi-core
machines and so the ask was positioned
literally as the
infrastructure to bridge that gap and i
think it was really well said in the
intro to the paper
yeah it's a super interesting super
valuable but also really hard problem
like it's not just a technology problem
you've got to get into a bunch of
different code bases you need to get a
bunch of different communities it was
like a social engineering
cultural problem to address here at the
same time you're building technology
had to be really unopinionated and very
receptive
in order to have the kind of impact it's
had and not just with pandas pandas is
you know maybe
twenty percent of das usage there's a
ton of other libraries
that leverage das today that rodask was
put in
after the fact it's like um it's like a
turbocharger to your car something you
add in
well then so so before we get into more
specifics on
what desk is what das does those kinds
of features
um since since you've sort of placed ask
against this backdrop of
the python ecosystem at large
explained to us what was going on in the
python ecosystem at that time
it was still mostly used for academic
scientific
research purposes no or are we
like what was it i guess google
obviously has been sort of a big python
production user since um the early to
mid 2000s but
what else what like is there is how do
you sort of frame the industry versus
research uh sort of curve that of python
adoption
yeah no there's a like we could write a
book about that topic i'll try to
constrain my answers
but um yeah so python started off as an
academic
educational language actually it was
designed to be easy to learn
it wasn't designed for data science it
wasn't designed for web programming it
was designed to be easy to learn in the
classroom
that ended up actually being really
really useful for growth right education
tends to be a great way to get
high growth if you're willing to wait 10
20 years
uh python then went into sort of web
development and syslops so that's
where google was using it a lot of web
developers used python
still not in data science then i think a
lot of the matlab
community shifted over and so python had
really really good connections to c
into fortran so it was very easy to take
some of these existing scientific
libraries
that were amazingly fast battle-hardened
code it's been around since the 70s and
just like you know runs your
local nuclear power plant um but make it
really accessible
and so that combination of speed and
accessibility ended up speaking really
really well to scientists
with a time where you know
semi-technical but not computer
wanted speed and i think over time it
ended up also being a really good proxy
for data scientists so i think python
really built out
its infrastructure serving the sort of
scientific need
and that gave it sort of this like this
head start on the same kinds of
computational accessibility needs that
data scientists and data engineers
needed as well
so that's where i think we've seen
python to sort of like suddenly leap
frog
into business because it has all of this
very interesting history with
with science um as an interesting
artifact a lot of people in charge all
the scientific life of all the python
libraries
we all have a science background and so
if you look at you know jupiter was
started by neuroscientists and quantum
physicists um you know psychic learn
also by by neuroscientists
but there's this like weird uh history
everyone who's
my age in the ecosystem and so from a
traditional
conversely from a traditional cs
perspective um
you know python programmers were always
kind of considered to be hacks
right it was uh yeah yeah yeah it was it
did didn't come from
from the the hardcore computer science
end of the spectrum
yeah i'm actually very atypical that i
do have a computer science degree i'm
like the weird guy who actually thinks
about distributed systems
but i also can kind of communicate with
everyone else in the community
um yeah i think python has always been a
very pragmatic language
distinguishes it for maybe like scala
which was like very theoretically pure
i think again that pragmatism really um
spoke to the eventual need in business
right so if you look at history there
was maybe like numpy and scipy and
second learn and then pandas shows up
that brings in finance psychology
machine learning
uh you know the deep learning frameworks
came in a few years ago and that brings
a lot of like heavy
heavier groups there's been this
transition away from science into
industry
over the last you know five to ten years
based on how you count it
and then as you mentioned even
underneath that there's this big
underpinning of just
mind share around python because so many
people had
bumped into it or brushed brushed had a
brush with it or learned it in school or
so there's this kind of quiet
groundswell of all these folks who had
experienced python in some educational
computer class or whatever that was
probably
also meaningful in just a very broad
sense yeah it's also i mean the fact
that there is a web stack attached to
python is amazing right i mean you can
build your machine learning model
and host it in the same language right
and it's actually quite hard to do that
in most other languages
there's no there's there probably is a
flask for scala but like it's not
something that i'm aware of
right it's the fact that both of those
are around are actually quite
quite convenient in more of a production
setting
so so your vision was to embrace the
reality
of increasing adoption of python
especially in the scientific computing
stack and
and produce more advanced a more
advanced system that could
parallelize workloads and do it in the
in similar ecosystem that
data scientists um using similar
libraries that they were already using
in uh in python
yeah what's my vision but that's our
vision generally
so what happened yeah go ahead people
love using python on a single machine
they run into a big data set and there's
this big well what do i do now question
and ask more or less lets them continue
doing what they're currently doing
with sort of minimal pain to scale out
rather than having to rewrite in some
other framework
mpi spark custom cues etc
and what happened i'm curious when the
paper was released was it obvious that
that you're to something or um
like what was going on in your in your
mind as the community started to respond
to this
um this new info and this this proposal
yeah it's only
it's funny funny you mentioned the
paperwork i think and no one reads that
paper
it was written as part of a conference
the scipy conference which all the
the python maintainers go to every year
um
most honestly the the biggest
thing that sort of advocated for for
desk was my personal blog
so i actually i blogged i live blog the
development
every few days during development i
would talk about what i was working on
and then actually that transparency i
think actually brought a lot of other
library authors
into the project really early we had
groups like psychic image or x-ray or
pandas
those maintainers started getting
involved really early because they saw
what we were doing
we're also very able to shift
development a lot
the task was very nimble we pivoted
quite a bit in the first few months
as we were getting used to work working
with these other library developers
i would say within a small number of
months two or three
we had excellent traction among other
core authors
and then you know a few months after
that we had good traction with their
users
and that really caused our um our growth
to increase
so task ends up being sort of more of an
infrastructural player that ends up
being sort of like an end-user
tool or user points so so just so i
understand so is this to say that you
were not just
building an open source project and sort
of um
you know soliciting community
contributions et cetera but you are also
blogging in english about design
decisions
and architectural um choices
and sort of you're you were showing your
work showing your mental work
if you will um sort of via blog posts as
you are also
contributing code and and pushing the
project forward from uh
from a bytes perspective yeah absolutely
so i mean i come and i come from like an
academic perspective and i
i think a lot better if i'm writing
something what i
what i do and so yeah das started very
much
in like a bottoms-up way we like made a
little task scheduler
we then tried to numpy around that we
then tried to do pandas around that we
then tried to do
lists around that and all of those were
little blog posts
we actually pulled all those things out
of my blog they all now live at
blog.dask.org
and so if you go to that webpage you can
actually see down to the very you know
the first week of development
it was i think christmas week i was off
on vacation
and you can see the very first thoughts
that were going through our heads as we
were working on it
that's great um you know that's a really
amazing story of
um the power of building something in
the open and and
and and showing your work with the
community and again i think that comes
from a lot of python's principles of
being
more academic a little more honest a
little more transparent
community-minded that's had great uh
that i think that has caused a lot of
tasks great success
is that that strong transparency and
community openness
awesome so um so let's get into the ask
a little bit more deeply
um favorite topic yeah
and now now we can talk for hours so
so um what are the main uses of desk
obviously to ask is
parallel computing for the python
ecosystem
maybe you describe it differently i
would love to
hear how you sort of in your own words
um what it is and what it's used for
yeah i think that's that's the correct
thing so people ask where's
where is desk used my response is
where's python used
and it's more or less the same set of
situations
um maybe i'll answer that with an
anecdote uh
please so we the original goal of das
was to paralyze numpy
numpy being this sort of
multi-dimensional gridded data structure
that's really really common
it backs more or less all of the python
ecosystem today for computation
the idea was like right we're going to
accelerate that and then everything else
will follow
that end up not being the case what
ended up happening is we we built that
we then built pandas uh on desk and then
we showed that to users and they said
about half of them said great this is
what i want i just wanted big pandas
i just want a big numpy this is perfect
then about half of them said
like actually like i don't really want
big pandas i'm doing something way more
complex than that
i'm building out my own custom thing but
the engine that you had to build in
order to paralyze numpy and pandas
that engine is actually really really
useful to me
um it is as though we had built a nice
car people said great i'll take the
engine please so i'm building a rocket
ship
or i'm building a submarine and this
speaks a little bit to i think how
python is used a little bit differently
from how
like most of the other data
infrastructure tooling is used
i think a lot of us come from more of
like a business intelligence standpoint
we think you got a table of customers
you then want to run some sql queries on
it
do some lightweight machine learning the
python users and organizations are often
far more creative
and they're they're doing weird
experiments they're trying to bring in
new different kinds of data sources
they're bringing some audio files
they're doing some other weird stuff
that really breaks the mold and so about
half of das usage
was was enabling those other experiments
a good example of this is like prefect
is a company
workflow management completely different
from big pandas
and they're built on top of desk or they
can use das under the hood to scale out
right and the fact that das like the
prefect authors sawdust said oh great
that's everything i need to sprinkle
parallelism
into my code base this very different
kind of code base
great and so really das is kind of this
you know magic
parallelism dust that other library
authors put into their code
but common use cases i would say it's
about a third big pandas about a third
big numpy which is you know imaging mri
climate science big industry and about a
third
wacky stuff which is you know common in
you know in hedge funds they've got
really advanced trading strategies that
are being run on desk because they're
just
it's just changing really quickly and
they need a lot of sort of very custom
stuff
you know credit risk models inside of
banks is really common uh
xg boost uh deploys on desk really
comfortably that's a very common uh
combination point
but yeah a bunch of stuff i'm happy to
get into particular workloads but the
the general answer is das is a very
general purpose
parallel computing platform which has
been so easy to integrate
then now there's a lot of a lot of
common use cases built around it
got it and so what's the typical
um entry point into das um for a
sort of production workload or a team
like when do you see
somebody is is it because they're
they're pandas data frames processing
um just isn't scaling the way they want
it to is that i assume that's a sort of
common on-ramp onto desk
are there others yeah so you maybe
you're on your laptop
and you you know i've been working with
csv files that are hundreds of megabytes
large
you'll be given a 20 gigabyte csv file
and your laptop doesn't have much ram
instead of importing pandas you import
dask and you just use das
on your laptop to process that much
larger file
that's probably the most common
individual use case
so task is you know it comes installed
by default with anaconda
most people have it on the laptop today
if they have sort of a data science
stack
and it's just the easiest thing to get
started with and they maybe will stop
there right you can actually do quite a
bit of computation
on a macbook pro right so if you sort of
go to the
20 50 100 gigabyte level like you're
probably comfortable just on your laptop
with desk
now you then could say well hey actually
there's this five terabyte data set
sitting on my company's cloud
how do i get das deployed on my
company's infrastructure to use it at
scale and
that's like a whole different paradigm
shift and people love it when that
happens
it gives you all this power that you're
already used to sort of the interface
it's it's very fun seeing people's eyes
light up
when suddenly they've got you know not
four little cores working on a laptop
but 400 working on the cluster
and it all feels the same it really
really connects the remote
infrastructure
makes it feel very close at hand it's a
really magical experience
and it's the same it's just so just to
be clear it's the identical code base
that scales to support all of these
additional cores
uh more or less they're like slight
differences my favorite example here is
you know if you want to compute the the
median of a data set
it's very hard to do that in parallel um
but you know das will provide
alternatives like approximate quantile
and so there's there's some things that
are different um yeah i mean the apis
like you know the
the pandas maintainers also maintain
task right when pandas makes a release
last release in lot releases
learn same with jupiter like we've got
the core maintainers of das are just the
pi data core maintainers
there's a lot of effort to make that
feel very very smooth
great so then let's talk a layer
lower so then what what is
infrastructure deployment
of diasporic what does that look like if
i am a data scientist and
all of a sudden i'm hitting the limits
of my macbook pro and i want to deploy
to a
cluster did you use the term cluster or
yeah um
so so so what has to happen at the
infrastructure level
in order for that to successfully happen
is that something i can do as a
data scientist or do i need my it team
to kind of get involved and
and install things and like what is that
and that's honestly what i mean i think
you're like
you're sort of a softball for me
well yeah so uh das the open source
project deploys on
any major resource manager uh that's
available today
so you have a bunch of physical hardware
somewhere on the cloud
in an on-prem uh rack somewhere and that
physical hardware probably runs one of
about five or six different resource
managers
kubernetes is an example of this uh it's
quite common today yarn is another one
that's called
a sort of older cloudera hadoop spark
system
if you want to sort of like hpc systems
you get names like sge
slurm condor lsf on ibm systems
et cetera and dash deploys on all of
those so you have access if you have
access to those things and you
understand enough about them
you can deploy das on whatever hardware
you have
now what's what's common is that your
data scientist in a company that has a
cloud access with kubernetes
you have no idea how that works and so
you i'm sure pete could easily deploy
dusk
but uh that and that's what we often see
we see early adopters in companies use
desk
and then getting sort of the rest of the
company involved it's a little bit
trickier
and like we can go into all the
challenges that people face there
got it so um so the the das
bits get installed on um
sort of a broad set of systems and then
they start to listen for workloads i
mean it's that the the general
idea yeah uh usually what happens is
that
das clusters are ephemeral and so you
say hey look i want to
look at this data set you ask kubernetes
hey give me a dash scheduler and 50
workers radius gives those to you you
know 10 seconds later
you can say great i want to go do some
query and then you know those workers do
some work
they fire off they read data they do
some pandas stuff they do some pie torch
things
they you know then give you a license
plot and you show that in your jupyter
notebook
or on your you know batch process or
whatever it is that you do
then maybe uh maybe you keep those
workers around for a long time if you're
gonna keep doing that work
if you've got a really advanced system
your system all they tell kubernetes to
scale that down
so you're not taking up money and we
asked another question that scales back
up again
right um bring the question of you know
they stick around for a long time
are they adaptive that's a sort of an
i.t
yep got it so then what are some of the
main challenges that companies have in
in migrating to desk obviously you've
seen
many different types and sizes of
companies and teams
work to get onto this platform over the
years like what are the main
pitfalls gotchas caveats sort of like
tips and tricks and hacks that you can
mention that that are insightful and and
honest
yeah no um um
i'm trying to like think about the
dishonest fun ones would be you're
you're nothing but honest so i i i don't
know why i said that but just trying to
spice it up a little bit yeah no i'll
i'll try to try to break the mold here a
little bit try to break the pattern
um no there's maybe two different kinds
of users we would talk to i'm now like
switching a little bit into for-profit
mode
uh there's like the small team
case so you know you pete maybe you're a
data science lead at a company
you you know you serve you know two to
ten people in your team
and you know you probably use desk and
you've used it you did the whole
kubernetes thing we just talked about
happy with it fantastic um
they're then like a bunch of extra
challenges right your teammates don't
know how to use the cloud they know how
to like turn on the kubernetes thing
on their on their cloud accounts maybe
you end up sort of managing that for
them you turn into about like a half to
quarter fde
sort of devops person challenge
you probably leave the cluster on for a
bit too long so like i t is kind of
concerned that this this stuff is
running all the time you've actually
forgotten a few clusters that have been
running for last few months
accidentally uh you're also running
python code like arbitrary python code
at scale across your corporate
infrastructure not any kind of security
and that might create some concerns as
well um
you got a team to manage but i want to
think about off some of your teammates
are
more diligent about turning things off
or on so you want to make some policies
and some quotas some team management
and so there's like a you know there's a
set of things you need to think about
and it ends up taking you know an itv
team six to 12 months to build
some semblance of this those may be like
the common gotchas
uh this is where i think so i've done
this i don't know how many times
different companies
we ended up making a separate company
coiled which just
has that service and it has all those
things built in and it's super easy to
use
um and that's maybe like one set of
concerns
at the like i t or top down level
there's a different set of concerns
just things like how do i use these gpus
how do i accelerate this credit risk
model
at scale instead of business questions
how do i make sure
that the ask you know doesn't break on
me how do i get enterprise support
so there's a kind of a different level
of questions that happen at that larger
scale
and so you saw enough of these questions
from
enough users you saw the growth of the
desk
footprint and implementation numbers
growing
and um were you getting bugged by
people in the open source community for
for more support than you can give and
hence like
it's time like it's this this company
like needs to happen
was it that simple or is there is there
something more there yeah no it's that
times 10. like i honestly i should have
done this a few years ago
[Laughter]
i mean so for reference i think like the
dash usage is quite high today
i think the python software foundation
did a survey they surveyed all python
users
uh and i think when asked the question
which big data framework do you use
i think like 12 say they use spark and
about five percent say they use desk
among python users and so we're like
kind of like below spark but above a
tool like hive
for example so turn that number around
any company with around 20 python users
probably has someone in the company
using desk today
and so the demand is is very high it was
very high a couple of years ago i was
actually going to make a company a
couple of years ago
when nvidia stepped in and asked me to
instead lead a team
they were sort of starting rapids at the
time they wanted me to lead their sort
of multi-gpu
data science story so i did that for a
year and then started going afterwards
but um yeah i mean demand is quite high
uh there's certainly a business here
um i should have done this a couple of
years ago
well that's great i mean this is an
amazing um
indicator and you know proof point for
other founders who might be
building popular open source stuff right
when you're when you're able to
release open source in the wild and see
significant adoption
um and the questions and the support
requests come back to you
that's one indicator that the the time
might be right to think about
commercializing something around it was
that difficult for you to
build a commercial entity around
something that you had built
in the open in the wild and had donated
to the community by your open source
efforts like how did you
how did you think about that um i mean
certainly making a company for anybody
is hard
i mean i've never met anybody who said
like oh this is easy yeah no my life is
much less fun now than it was
managing engineering teams um
in terms of bringing in kind of a
for-profit angle that hasn't been much
of a problem
i think i mean i've always worked at
for-profit companies
and working on desk right anaconda
generously donated my time
and video that relationship donated my
time
to ask is maybe distinct in the open
source python space
then we always have been relatively well
funded by for-profit companies and yet
we've also managed to maintain this sort
of multi-institution
community-oriented transparency that i
think you need to be this kind of
infrastructural
project you know like i think kubernetes
did this well as well right kubernetes
is maybe a google project but they're
really it's really managed by a bunch of
different organizations
tensorflow is maybe the like the counter
example right tensorflow is very much
dominated by one company
we've we've taken steps to make sure
that das is does not feel like that
and so coiled feels like my next thing
but not necessarily
uh fully encompassing of desk itself
and anaconda quansite nvidia capital one
these are all companies that provide a
lot of support around desk
that's great i think it's it's good for
us as a community to have discussions
around
um how the open source world and
commercialization options are evolving
because
you know as wes mckinney has noted um
you know his concern is like is is this
really
sustainable over time um if we don't
figure out some longer tail
version of how open source developers
get paid because if we're just looking
to the big companies
um to subsidize your time to contribute
to desk
or other big projects like is is that
the only model or is there something
that's slightly more robust and
community driven that
we need to be thinking about and talking
about as well this is obviously a bigger
can of worms but you might have some
quick thoughts there
yeah i've got lots of not quick thoughts
there too as well
um yeah people share some thoughts that
i think i came to while at nvidia
nvidia is a weird case right because
nvidia
is definitely a for-profit company right
there's no
there's no conclusion that they're not
there just to make them they sell
hardware
yeah right but they sell hardware it's
this yeah yeah they actually
don't want software lock-in they want
hardware lock-in
and so they're actually very much
incentivized to be a good player when it
comes to software kind of one layer
separated i think i give a talk about
this at scipy
2019 people want to look at that talk
and i think
that open source right now is in a good
position
because we have enough mindshare that we
can define the rules of the game
where those rules are protocols and
conventions and interfaces
that anybody who wants to have access to
our users has to abide by
so for example a lot of libraries today
look a lot like numpy or they look a lot
like pandas
or look a lot like scikit-learn even if
they're doing their own very proprietary
stuff
and i think that while we still have
that power that control we need to
really harden and make sure those
interfaces and those protocols
uh are solid and that that defines the
game
that then all the companies can come
into and play on
so nvidia for example we worked very
hard so that numpy
and a gpu equivalent to numpy could both
work in a lot of different software
libraries
that required a lot of sort of community
effort but now as a result you know if
google comes in with tpus or other
hardware
they can play in that same level playing
field
and so i think that's our goal to kind
of solidify those
contracts the software contracts so that
everyone from now on is kind of forced
into that convention
this may be an overly technical
description but i think there's
like a nice interesting point right now
to control the game
yeah no i love it i think i think that's
a great point
um so just to sort of go back to
to the company um i'm wondering about
your
some of your thoughts on on go to market
right um
open source projects have a distinct
advantage in some ways
in getting this grassroots bottoms up
community traction um but but as
you know putting your your ceo and
founder hat on
how are you thinking about enhancing
that
go to market um on behalf of of coiled
um and and asked sort of do you have a
quick
mental model as to how you're thinking
about sort of pouring gasoline on this
on this python
slash desk adoption in the enterprise
like where
are you just going to let it ride from
an open source standpoint
yeah no um yeah i actually come from
more of a consulting background like
i've had to fight for dollars in the
past
people directly this whole vc thing is
new for us
um uh so yeah we're not just doing just
like straight up open source
until we clearly dominate the space i
think we've kind of clearly dominated
the space right now
right now the goal is to capture that
grassroots adoption
and see what we can do to grow it and
see what we can do to monetize it
certainly bottoms up makes a lot of
sense for us and
we actually started with a top-down
enterprise sale
mostly because i happen to know a bunch
of finance companies using that
um we were urged early on to go bottoms
up and that actually was i think really
good advice
uh we still have like 95 of our money
comes from
a few large enterprises mostly in the
financial services
but you know like 99 of our users are
small teams
um and understand of our information
coming in is small teams
so we're doing a bit of both um
i would say for the next year we're
probably very much focused on bottoms up
and that's that's that sort of team lead
role that i talked about before
and that that conversation is just
really repeatable
uh the sales cycle for that is is weeks
not
years um and that's like definitely been
uh
a lot more informative than the sort of
long
selling to it selling to top down uh
sales cycles
which we've done but it's like it takes
nine months and we're 12 months old
so it's we had to do something those
intervening nine months engineering-wise
um but it is a challenge like i do
we have enough large finance companies
and enough like government organizations
for example
all of who want to use us and all of
them are very strictly on-prem
that it you know there's you know many
millions of dollars in ar we could
capture if we wanted to
um we don't have to we've got venture
capital money to like do this bottom-up
thing for a while
it's very tempting to go back over
lessons from databricks or snowflakes
say go bottoms up but it's it's not
entirely clear that that's the right
case for us it's an interesting
i think about today um
i think it's a very open very
interesting question
well i'm uh really curious to see how
this
evolves for you i mean obviously you're
a community
oriented kind of a guy but it's nice
that
at least you know that there's big
company interest and there are revenues
to capture their
um depending on sort of how the company
might
want to pivot its go to market if if
that becomes necessary in the future
yeah i think again bottoms up makes
sense we're kind of building all those
leagues in the future
but it's nice knowing that we are able
to close large
top-down fields because it makes it very
clear we're on the right
path and so the planets you know make a
few large enterprises happy
while building out a large set of
customers and then you know
a year two or three in the future you
know turn those smaller customers into
larger customers
correct um besides the go to market
questions like what's been the most
challenging thing about starting a
company
as an engineer i think there's lots of
people in our community who would
would love to know like what what's
waiting around the corner for them
i would say there's not a most
challenging thing there's a there's a
every
couple of weeks there's a new most
challenging thing like the job that
never stops changing
um uh we've actually started hiring a
bunch right now
uh and actually having more seasoned
people in the company
realizing i don't have to do everything
on my own has been a huge way off my
shoulders that first year was really
really hard
um maybe that's maybe a good um
that's a good lead into a solid piece of
advice
i think as as maybe like a a good
engineer
or a good manager i'm very used to being
able to say like look
if things going slowly i can just like
put my head down and solve this problem
quickly
and i think now that i'm no longer good
at my job right like being a founder of
ceo like it's just a constant flow of
not being good at your job
i think um learning to delegate more is
probably something that people with my
background
probably do need to figure out sooner
rather than later um
yeah i'm learning that you need to like
rely on other smart people i think it's
also something that
um i've always the people have hired
have always been like slightly
they've been like extensions of me i've
like given them engineering time
now i'm hiring people who actually are
more experienced than me and are taking
on functions
much better than i can and i think
getting that shift right
at the center of the organization rather
than the top of their organization
a shift that needs to happen especially
again for engineers because we tend to
be
maybe high performing individuals in the
thing
yeah absolutely i think an engineering
founder has to learn how to hire two
different
groups of people there's people who are
fundamentally different than you
first of all just in personality or
approach or style and then there's
um you have to build the sales org and
the marketing org and the
you know the the recruiting org and
there's all these different
types of roles to hire for as well so
um it's it's challenging as a founder to
figure out one's path through all of
these minefields
but it helps to have great investors
advisors mentors friends
other founders to talk to um so you know
thank god we have
a community of people who are willing to
support us and
in starting sort of bringing these
visions to life in a way that actually
can scale through a team when some of us
haven't had
huge experience in building huge teams
before we started our first companies
so yeah definitely just to echo that a
little bit there's a huge amount of
empathy
coming from other people who've done
this before which is
yeah that's awesome well i'm glad you're
able to step into that it's a it's a i
think it's a tremendous time to be a
founder and to
be starting a company because there's so
many different kinds of help
um and networks of support that you can
get right now so it's a golden golden
era to start a company for certain
certainly yeah but i'll also say i mean
from a
from an engineering perspective like
there are things that we've achieved
through a company
for the open source community that we
never could have done on our own
but in my little call to action here for
a second so you asked before hey if i'm
at a company and i want to figure out
how to add a scale desk how do i how do
i do that
right now if you're a python user you
can install coil
it's a python library you can pivot a
condom style coiled
and you can import coil into anywhere
you're using python and you can then
like
get a fully secure fully managed fully
authenticated
fully controlled running on your cloud
of choice
inside of your own vpc in your own
account in about two minutes
right and so like that huge sort of
devops problem that a lot of these early
users were facing
is solved um if you're willing to pay
coiled some fraction
of what you would pay normally um and so
i think that like again is a thing that
we really couldn't have solved as an
open source community building service
like that i think does require a company
behind it
to keep something up running all the
time to hire different kinds of
individuals to work on
and that capability is genuinely novel
that's a capability that has focused
if you go like the das conference from
last year
a third of the conference was about how
to solve this problem in different ways
and it's now like i think coil has made
it trivial
and that i think is is a big boost to
productivity
both for us as a company but also to you
know climate science
or or or medicine or there's a lot of
use cases that we're serving in our
broader mission that i think are
are very well served by the fact that we
have built this thing
as a company it's uh yeah that's that's
really well said
and um i think that goes back to the
previous question about
um you know you not having cognitive
dissonance over
both contributing to open source and
building a commercially viable company
around it because there are
truly powerful things that happen on
both ends of that
decision that um that that couldn't
exist
otherwise yeah the open source community
is very good at some things
it's very bad at others and you need a
healthy mix of
non-profit for-profit institutions all
mixed together
and building that culture is interesting
right and that's i think we've done a
very good job of that in the python
space
probably i think anaconda for example
did that quite well
um but that's that's certainly a
challenge and there's lots of
interesting back
and forth
yeah for sure it's fun i hope that
continues maybe going back to wes's
earlier point
but i think right now we're in a good
spot there's a lot of money floating
around there's a lot of respect to open
source contributors and community
it's a good time i think companies like
ours are
are furthering that same good time
but there's a fight to be made there
right and we have to make sure that you
know
other shark-like companies don't show up
and right
and just take and just and just monetize
and that's really important
that i and other folks like wes have
well yeah that's that's really well said
and um i've enjoyed the conversation
that it's been um great to chat from
chat with you um before i let you go i'm
curious
if there's something that surprised you
most about
working in the data ecosystem over the
years
um i would say personally it's been it's
been amazing fun i think there's there's
very few
disciplines where you get to touch so
many different kinds of problems
fairly deeply i feel like researchers
everywhere just welcome you into their
hardest problems
asking for advice and that's a really
unique opportunity i'd recommend this
field for anybody who's sort of
naturally curious about the world i
would say maybe a flip to that
it's also very surprising how frequently
their problems are all the same problems
um and so i think we're also like well
positioned playing that role
to unite a lot of these different groups
and bring them together
so if you go to again a das conference
maybe another call action you go to
summit.org
we're doing a user conference in may so
people who may be interested in
subscribing to that great and you see
astronomers and you see
geneticists and you see hedge fund
managers
and you see banks all talking about file
formats
uh and it's actually very fun to have
those all those very smart people
all in the same room um it's great like
it's a it's a very interesting
convergence
of different intellectual disciplines
that's happening right now
right around technology and that's
summit.dasc.org
yes great we'll make sure and uh put
that in the chat window so folks can
find that link easily well well thanks
matt it's uh been great to chat with you
i really appreciate you
being here with us today yeah this is a
blast thanks pete
so just to let our community know uh
there's a couple of
quick things i wanted to run run by with
you
first of all thanks again to ibm uh who
sponsored this episode has been a big
supporter of dc thursday
don't forget to hit subscribe and hit
the bell icon so that you get
notifications when we go live again next
time
you can leave us comments about today's
episode via our feedback form if you are
willing to sound off and let us know
what we could do better
we greatly appreciate that and then
finally
our next episode will be on march 18th
and we'll have will falcon who is very
involved
also in the the python community this
time on the pie torch side
and will's the founder of a company
called grid ai so he'll be joining us
for our next dc thursday
on march 18th